the united states will keep around 650
of its troops in afghanistan after the
rest of its forces
are withdrawn most of the more than 4
000 u.s soldiers have been leaving
afghanistan in recent months
as part of a pledge by president joe
biden to withdraw troops by september
11th
meanwhile afghanistan's president ashraf
ghani is due to meet
joe biden at the white house in the
coming hours
well also on friday u.s secretary of
state anthony blinken acknowledged
attacks on afghan forces were increasing
and that washington is assessing if
plans for peace are realistic
we're looking very carefully at
at the situation on the ground in
afghanistan and we're also
looking very hard at uh whether the
taliban
is at all serious about a peaceful
resolution to the conflict we continue
to be engaged
on the diplomacy but actions that would
try to take
the uh the country by force are of
course totally inconsistent
with um finding a peaceful uh resolution
well osama bin laden's joining us now uh
from doha osama one would imagine that
people in afghanistan
are wondering what kind of support the
u.s is going to be giving to afghanistan
if most of its troops aren't there but
also of course
what role the taliban plan to play in
the future of the country
well that is the big question since last
year when this landmark deal was signed
between the americans
and the taliban and then uh an interior
of one agreement with which
were supposed to start an intra-afghan
dialogue to find a lasting solution for
peace in the country
but that does not seem to have made the
headway that people were supposing that
it would
and to discuss that troop withdrawal uh
we have with this the spokesman for the
taliban and we'll we'll ask them
what do they feel about these 650 troops
which are going to
uh be staying in afghanistan according
to reports so mr suelshahn thank you
very much for being with us
uh now you've seen these reports that
650 u.s
troops are going to be stationed behind
let's start off with what is the
taliban's reaction
and how is that going to change the
situation
on the ground because more than a since
it's been more than a year since you've
attacked
american and nato forces uh we have
signed doha agreement and
that was negotiated with the american
side for 18 months
and they have agreed and committed
themselves
that they will withdraw from afghanistan
all their military forces advisors
and contractors i think it is a clear
violation of that agreement secondly
it is will not sold
the issue of afghanistan which has not
been
sold resolved through military approach
in the past 20 years but only
prolong the hardship the suffering
and complicate the issue but the
situation has not changed
even when the withdrawal was announced
you're seeing a number of attacks
on the afghan government areas you claim
that more than 100
district centers have fallen to the
taliban so
isn't there a reason for international
troops to stay there to maintain the
peace
because the fear is that the taliban
wants to take over afghanistan by force
first we had committed ourselves that
we will provide secure passage
to the americans to the americans while
they are withdrawing from afghanistan
and we will not attack them we remained
loyal to that we have not attacked them
during
their withdrawal even that they violated
the first me full withdrawal from
afghanistan
still we have not attacked them while we
are
fully capable to do that and secondly
is the internal aspect of the upgrade
issue
that is we reach a solution in a c-spire
through intra-afghan negotiation which
we see
the other side from the kabul they
do not do not show flexibility
so that is why the the progress is very
slow
for example uh about the regarding the
release of our 5000
prisoners they delayed that for six
months
not releasing that it was one of the
reason
of slow progress in the talks it is
i think that the other side also be
blamed
and even when we started the entire bar
negotiation
they were not ready to accept the doha
agreement as a basis for the
intra upon negotiation why it was it is
on the basis of that
agreement that we started uh intra
afghan negotiation before that
we were not ready and there was no intra
upon negotiation
so it is very important that they show
uh
flexibility and come uh that it is a
reconciliation
but the question is that is that
flexibility being shown by your side
as well uh because the kabul
administration as you call it has been
saying that the taliban want a return to
power
a return to the islamic emirate they're
not flexible about
coming to the democratic system for
instance will the taliban take part in
elections how
will this process work if it's going to
be both sides coming together towards a
mutual agreement
i think that concept that to impose
what they say to improve that and ask
why
then why we have the interrupt one
negotiation we didn't
say any uh anytime that
we impose anything on them we say it is
up to the true negotiation team to reach
our solution
and to talk about a future government
and then it will be acceptable to us
but they before uh the two teams decide
of the
about the future islamic government they
say
you should accept this kind of
government and this
and that so that is i think they are not
in the mode of reconciliation but rather
they want
uh surrendering while this
negotiation this intra of one
negotiation which is underway in dawah
it is for reconciliation between
the parties not uh surrendering so
i think they are a kind up in a vacuum
very quickly uh this u.s troop
stationed 650 if they stay behind are
the taliban going to attack u.s troops
now
yes or no if they stay here
then i think it is a kind uh a kind of
continuation
of the occupation and that's they have
violated
and we have fully right to react mr sway
shahin thank you very much for speaking
to us there you have it the reaction
from the taliban
on the reports of 650 u.s soldiers
staying inside afghanistan as the
withdrawal is underway and
violence is speaking at levels that we
have not seen
for the last few years and peace in
afghanistan
after all of the negotiations which
happened between various sides and
including
regional actors remains a distant
possibility
that's osama bin lade reporting from
doha osama thank you